welcome into wrigley field as we get
ready for baseball here this afternoon
the first of three cubs and cardinals
and
one hundred percent capacity nicole
stewart
for seymour sinker cutter so a lot of
hard stuff
and that one in the air out towards left
center that's chris bryant gliding to
his right
and that one softly hit back to the
mound and cole stewart gets him quickly
and quietly one two three
johan oviedo
gets the call today
and opponents
five hits or less since seven of his ten
career major league starts and yet he's
still looking for that first win facing
jack peterson's in that lead off spot
jack hammers that one on the line face
it right field
here's a 3-2 pitch peterson is running
on the 3-2 swinging a miss throw down to
second it's a double play nice pick by
carpenter double play strike him out and
throw him out
first game in a cardinal uniform at
wrigley field
swaying and a miss
and stewart strikes him out he went
upstairs highest percentage of batted
balls resulting in extra base hits it's
this guy at the plate ahead of ohtani
fan mail reyes mike trout fernando tatis
jr
and now he's hit by the pitch that
normal greeting that yadier molina gets
anywhere within the division the chorus
of boos
up the middle and it's a base hit for
yachty into center field
you ride the hot ham when you've got one
and right now they've got one in matt
carpenter
and a base hit into right field o'neal
being waved in
and the throw by hayward is cut off and
it's one nothing cardinals
out at third yadir molina
[Applause]
popped up rizzo shading his eyes
wandering over
he's got it
one nothing cardinals on the matt
carpenter rbi single
and a swing and a miss strikeout number
two for johann oviedo
and he struck him out back-to-back case
for johann oviedo
[Applause]
and back to first but oviedo
scrambles back in there's the gold
glover at shortstop i don't know if
javi's 100 yet with that thumb but there
was no way he wasn't going to play in
this ball game
good work by oviedo who has not spent a
lot of time on the base pass
a good rate and able to scramble back
june is goldie's best month over his
career in terms of average home runs
runs batted in
the 2-2
and goldie rips it
for a base hit into left past the diving
patrick wisdom orinato struck out
swinging his first time up
[Applause]
and ornato sends it into right center
diving catch no he couldn't come up with
it
may have had it in the glove it popped
out great attempt by hayward arnotto the
base hit that scores a run and it's two
to nothing st louis
check swing did he go yes he did
and so stewart
the strikeout of o'neill as we take a
look at best record in the national
league since april 29th and it's your
chicago cubs at 25 and 13. you know for
the most part that record coincides with
you know at least in part the return of
jack peterson
that one drilled out towards right
center back there that's got a chance
jack into the basket
it's his eighth
and the cubs have cut the cardinal lead
in half
[Applause]
he tried to change up there
and
generally change-ups that finish
belly button high
[Applause]
we talk about his ability to hit the
high fastball with velocity but
you're right you hang a change up to a
left-hand hitter in the middle of the
plate like that and more often than not
you're gonna end it asking the umpire
for a new baseball
bryant drills that one towards left
center o'neal is there
[Applause]
a swing and a miss strikeout number five
for johan oviedo
and the ground ball to goldie oviedo to
the bag and the out
tommy edmond takes a foul ball off his
right leg he is over two flied to center
and lined out to short
edmond
a base hit into right field
two aboard for dylan carlson
and carlson hits one out to center brian
is back and it's off the top of the ivy
in the wall
oviedo will score
and it's a double for dylan carlson and
the cardinals have regained their
two-run lead
it's keegan thompson on for the 13th
time
21 in the third innings a 2.11 era lola
oronato has been an rbi machine 41 now
on the season a chance to pick up a
couple of more stakes right here
and that's lined into the gap in left
center one run is in that's tommy edmond
here comes another dylan carlson and
aronado has brought in three this
afternoon
it's now a 5-1 st louis league
[Applause]
drifting back chris waits under it
and that is out number three
[Applause]
[Music]
that's drilled into right center base in
edmond over to cut it off and racing for
third is contreras they're at the
corners
jay hay with a solid single right-hander
kicks deals
inside and it gets past molina here
comes contreras and the cubs get a run
back it's 5-2 and hayward down to second
on a wild pitch
3-2
that's drilled right center field lots
of space and watching run
hayward coming in alcantara around
second
on his way to third and he's in it's a
triple and it's a two-run game i mean
he's really showing some pop with his
back low fastball down below the knees
and take a look at that swing head right
on it
quack
[Applause]
snap throw to third and it gets away
two miscues by molina and it's a one-run
game
peterson with a fly ball
into right center the catch made by
carlson he'll throw back to the baggage
first and save it first his half is just
in there
center field
carlson and the catch
he had a swing and a miss
bounce back to the mound loved by names
the second for one on the first great
turn
the longer that this at bat goes on it
feels like something good is going to
happen for the hitter
[Applause]
oh my goodness
are you kidding
me what an effect from anthony rizzo an
absolute marathon is he excited
14 pitches 10 fouls nine with two
strikes
and what a curtain call
oh yeah they do
[Applause]
high chopper could be trouble with the
speed of hayward and it is it's a base
head
that'll get down hayward around second
jason makes his way to third as maurizio
found space into right
and they're on the corners
[Applause]
have a day jock peterson a solo homer
that got the crowd going and then a
two-run double to give him the lead
the o2
and struck him out contreras will come
up to him wood for deals
and that one drilled right field this
one's got a chance on its way gone
insurance in the eighth contreras is
11th and it is eight to five he goes the
opposite way
swinging in a mess and he's gone and
that is the ball game comes with
opening day 2.0 a success indeed